hey guys so right now I'm standing in
front of a polar bear we post the paper
bear fact that you had read it about I
come are actually nice one right now in
case you guys didn't know I can't
remember oh he's like swimming very
unlikely
so I'm actually recording this right now
on my iPad because I dropped my phone
well actually I didn't drop it I had a
waterproof case on it but the waterproof
case failed so I was in the Blue Lagoon
when I was like this is the coolest
thing ever
like this is amazing and well I lost all
the footage so I apologize you'll never
get to see that look at this hallway so
I haven't been able to post any updates
because we've been doing crazy
adventures I don't know if this is
actually gonna post because the Wi-Fi
where we are is is not okay
yeah that's true so I should probably
keep it short anyway we have 315 not a
baby so do you wanna tell you guys that
we're doing you meet up its act a mall I
don't know how to pronounce it so I will
put it in the description is this Sunday
it'll be at 3 o'clock
what teen 13th
well whatever sunday is which would be
tomorrow it's at 3 o'clock come say hi
I'm so excited because honestly one
moment in recording yes I am guys sorry
filming on an iPad let me show you what
you look like this is what I look like
okay umm yeah this is really not main
channel video quality but I have no
other way to talk to you guys so I hope
that I will be able to see you all at
the meetup because one of my most
favorite made up said I've ever done was
the one that I did in Norway you guys
were just amazing and it's so cool to
just be in an entirely different place
than I'm used to and meet you guys
so hopefully I'll get to see you guys
there we're
so taking votes right now for our next
project committee adventure what is it
look it up oh no oh no it's either
longaville a snowball mill or a
longboard
I don't shoot okay I'll put them in the
distribution um so you guys just have to
tweet us the hashtag and make sure you
guys look at the scripture no because I
don't know what the hashtags are right
now so hopefully yeah so look in there
tweet us see you guys Sunday come
prepared to give hugs and shoot wait no
no I just got a text message it's
longboarding and Viking horses yeah oh
my god that text came in like at the
most time ever
so it's either or biking horses hashtags
in the description honestly I feel like
I feel like Walter Mitty I look I think
I in him I'm in it so call me Walter
well Walter Mitty okay we need a pack oh
yeah who's he finish packing we're gonna
go climb a glacier cuz that's what you
guys voted on for the last of it
I just carb loaded for it I didn't want
to tell you about my yesterday I have to
go because I'm hoping that this will
post I don't think I've ever actually
made a video on his iPad and I don't
know where to look I think yep right
here I should have been looking here not
over here at this sir oh okay I love you
guys I'll see you soon um that's all
I've got okay bye
where's the stop button here you are I
miss my iPhone so much okay so don't
stop oh my goodness